hello everybody I am Adam Armand ski my
wife Rose my son George and my daughter
C morning and we are from Brazil from
the state of Santa Catarina the city of
joint village and we are in unique
because Munich is one of the most
important city in Germany
very very nice very different I never
have son saw something like this all the
surroundings are very very beautiful
very different from our country because
our country is relatively new
we are from thousand five hundred and
something and probably these beauties
oldest than our country let's go there
beautiful church
I very press yeah I think it's the the
most beautiful church that I saw in my
travel it's really amazing it's a small
church but very very beautiful very yes
impressive it's even it's it's it's
difficult to breathe inside
I made a restoration of a Honda 1975 but
nothing compared with this
nothing better than finished travel to
Munich with a good beer
you want to discover Germany welcome to
our website for more information and
inspiration concerning your trip to
Germany visit our website at DW de
forward slash visit Germany here you can
also watch discover Germany your
favorite Travel Show visit Germany
whenever you want and wherever you are
by clicking on DW de /z Germany